Here I have an interesting system,
I have two compartments - in the left compartment I have gas,
which has a temperature of T with index a,
and on the right side I have a gas that has a temperature T with index b.
They are separated by a wall of depth d,
or suppose you can say in thickness d.
And the contact area of ​​the wall,
or the contact area of ​​the gas with the wall,
this area is A - and draw only part of it,
we assume that these two compartments are completely separated.
Now I'm curious - and we will accept,
that the temperature on the left is higher than the temperature on the right
and therefore you will have a heat transfer
from left to right.
And the heat that is transferred is called heat
and we will label it with the letter Q.
I wonder how the speed at which heat is transferred,
or how much heat is transferred per unit of time -
this is the rate at which heat is transferred -
how this will change, depending on it
how we change these different variables.
For example, if our contact area increases,
what will this do for Q / t?
Then Q / t will also increase for a unit of time,
because I have more space,
in which these hot air particles or molecules
can crash, and heat that wall.
And then there will be a more heated wall,
which will heat up the colder air particles.
That is, in this case, the rate of heat transfer will also increase.
And obviously, if I make my area smaller -
maybe I have to explicitly write down this -
and if I make my contact area smaller,
then my heat transfer rate will decrease
and this seems to be self-explanatory.
And what about thickness?
If you increase the thickness,
if I make this wall thicker,
what will it do with my transfer rate of heat?
Then I will have more things to warm up,
to make them with a certain temperature,
which can then heat the particles to the right
and obviously this is a continuous process -
it will always be done, but there will be more things to heat up.
And it will take more and more of this kinetic energy,
this average kinetic energy will be displaced in this wall,
if this wall becomes thicker.
If the wall gets thicker,
then the heat transfer rate will decrease.
Or if the wall becomes thinner, if this depth is reduced,
then the heat transfer rate will increase.
That is, you can say that the speed of heat transfer
will be inversely proportional to the thickness of the wall.
What else can we think of?
Well, for the differential temperature.
This is T with index a minus T with index b.
If this temperature differential increases, what will happen?
By the way of logic we understand that if this is super hot here,
it's much hotter than the right,
then more heat will be transferred.
You will have more heat transferred per unit of time,
then the heat transfer rate will increase.
Similarly, if this difference decreases -
and you can take the extreme case -
if there is no difference -
if T with index a was the same as T with index b,
then you will not have heat transfer in any time unit.
It is logical that the heat transfer rate
will be proportional to the temperature difference.
How can we gather all these logical reasoning
in a formula to describe the thermal conductivity,
to think how quickly this heat will be transferred,
the heat transfer rate?
We can say that the rate of heat transfer -
and I hope you know that this stems from our intuition
for what is happening here - the speed of heat transfer,
I can say that this will be proportional to -
what will this be in proportion?
It will be proportional to the area -
the more surface area we have on this wall, the more contact area,
the more heat will be transferred per unit of time,
so this will be proportional to this contact area.
It will also be proportional to the temperature differential,
so let's multiply this by the temperature difference,
ie T with index a minus T with index b.
And this is inversely proportional to the thickness of the wall,
that is to say, the thickness of the wall.
Another thing you can say is:
"Okay, I have this ratio of proportionality,
but will not this be different for different materials?
For example, if it was a metal wall, would it not have to carry heat faster,
than if it were a wooden wall? "
And that's true - a metal wall would do it.
This K, this K here
depends on the material - what the wall is made of.
The material on the wall.
And you can measure this and the different materials
will have different thermal conductivity,
which this variable will represent here.
With a little intuition, we were able to find what looks like a twisted formula
and sometimes you will see this formula like
& quot; solid conductivity thermal conductivity formula & quot ;,
but it actually comes in a logical way.
The amount of heat transferred over time
will be proportional to -
and the proportionality factor will be material dependent.
Styrofoam, for example, will have a very low coefficient,
that's why the coolers are made of styrofoam.
And it will depend on the area,
will be proportional to the area,
the temperature difference,
and then it will be inversely proportional to the thickness.
That is, if you want to isolate something,
you will want to minimize surface area
and you want to maximize the thickness,
and you want to have something with very low thermal conductivity.
So a thick wall of styrofoam, which may be a sphere,
it can be a pretty good vessel to keep something hot or cold.